>>Our next question is from Student Kirk Charles,
and he has quite a story here.
Okay, "So we know Peter is very excited about launching his
new search engine business." This is true.
SearchWithPeter.info is actually launched.
>>It's a really cool site
>>Yeah I put a lot of work into it
Web 2.0 and all that.
"Let us suppose he is targeting the underserved
market of Klingon language web searches.
Let us suppose also that he is writing some
custom hashing procedure. After 8 months of
explosive growth in business," I hope so, "Peter finds that
he needs to double the number of buckets in his hash table.
He also finds that the hash buckets are not utilized evenly,
since he did not understand the hashing of Klingon
very well." Sounds like a hard problem.
So, his question is "How can we re-hash the index
without service interruptions? This is made more difficult
by the fact that his user base may get violent,
if he delays search results. Additionally the long latency
of intergalactic networks means he also needs to carefully
roll out a new hash."
Which strategy should he, I guess I, take?
>>Wow, well this is quite a question from Captain Kirk.
I'm glad he is hoping for the success of SearchWithPeter.info.
And thinking about the future is an important thing to do
I think one thing I understand is Klingon name servers don't
support the ".info" domain. So I think you're probably
safe from the Klingon attack for now, but it's a good
question to think about when you have to re-hash a table.
So we've been talking about
the standard way a hash table works. Once the
buckets get too full, or the load factor is too high,
you want to create a new table with more buckets,
and you've got to copy all your entries to it.
If you're running a big service like SearchWithPeter.info,
you don't want to shut down your service while you do that.
That would get people pretty annoyed.
If they're Klingons, you don't want to get them annoyed.
So what you could do instead and there are lots of
different things, and I don't know what Google does,
I'm sure there are lots of solutions that are possible,
and they've figured out something that works well.
One thing to do would be start a new copy,
so you keep the search engine going, still responding
to queries using the old hash table
but you start a separate process of running on
a separate computer, something that's making a new
copy of the hash table with a larger number of buckets.
Then when you're done with that, you switch them over and
you have the larger table with new buckets going.
Other than the switch over, there's no interruption
in service when you do that. There's some things
that make this hard. You've gotta worry about
"Well what if a new entry is added to the hash
table while you're in the middle of copying it."
You could lock it, make it so you can't add add any new
entries during that time. That might be a bad thing
if it takes a long time to copy. You could
maybe add the entry to both hash tables.
Every time a new entry is added, you add it to
both the original one and the copy as you're developing it.
You could save the updates and apply them all later
after you finish the copy.
So there are lots of tough problems to solve
to make this work without interruptions,
but it's definitely an important question to think about
if you're building SearchWithPeter.info,
and you have a lot of angry Klingons.
>>I probably should have been taking notes.
>>Depending on the service.
Well, we'll see. Hopefully the Klingons
don't know where you live.
>>We've recently reached 50 users
on SearchWithPeter.info.
We had a cake, and threw a party, it was pretty cool.
>>Cool, congratulations
>>Thank you.